thirty thousand hotel casino workers
still without jobs tonight that
according to the culinary union and many
tourists taken of social media sharing
their observations
about the need for more workers eight
news now reporter victoria saha live in
the strip with a closer look at why jobs
aren't back even though
it looks like tourism may be victoria
yeah yep so these observations are
coming from social media from guests and
even some workers who say that they
can't keep up with demands because they
are not fully staffed yet
i reached out to the culinary union who
tells me only half of their 60 thousand
members
are back to work they say they are
fighting for their workers to return to
the jobs they had pre-pandemic
but there's an issue here it's not the
matter of filling up these positions
but according to the culinary union
places like station casinos that fired
thousands of people during the pandemic
are now wanting the workers to reapply
and compete for the jobs they had before
and they say it's not right station
station casinos responded by saying
well over a thousand of our former team
members have returned to work at various
station casinos properties
and they're all being paid at the same
or at a higher rate
and are receiving the same or even
better benefits upon rehiring
and that doesn't even include the large
increase to wages we made just last
month
the nevada resorts association tells us
in part as occupancy levels are
increased and visitation builds
and becomes more predictable we will see
more employees return
which is what our members have been
looking forward to since the march
closure now i did reach out to several
resorts in our area so far
wynn and mgm say they cannot comment on
this but the venetian did get back to me
and they say that they are not
experiencing a staffing shortage
reporting live from this trip victoria
saha
8 news now